et elle nous a rejoints pour son coup de
coeur loisirs mélanie poquet bonsoir
onssa de la rédaction de tv 78 la ryder
cup c'était il ya tout juste un an à
saint quentin en yvelines mais
l'agglomération n'a pas dit au revoir au
golf pour autant dans quelques jours
c'est l'open de france qui débute et ce
week-end les curieux vont pouvoir s'y
essayer au golf et oui samedi à 5
octobre ce sera la 7e édition de
l'événement
ça se déroule ça se déroule au golf blue
green sur l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines avant d'en découvrir
un peu plus un mot de bernard des bancs
vice président aux sports
je crois que la ryder cup a fait
connaître largement le golfe mais
aujourd'hui il faut montrer que seul le
golf est accessible à tout le monde et
si le but en fait de cette manifestation
c'est de faire découvrir le golf de
façon ludique et pour tous de façon
gratuite alors les premiers potes seront
donnés à 14 heures avec les ateliers
d'initiation qui sont encadrés par les
golfeurs de l'asm golf ça c'est plutôt
pour les débutants on va dire pour ceux
qui pratiquent déjà j'ai dit si golf ou
proposera des analyses et des tests et
vous pourrez même faire durer la soirée
puisque à partir de 20 heures et jusqu'à
minuit le parcours va se faire en
nocturne le practice sera éclairé
ambiancé par un dj et entre 700 et 1000
personnes sont attendues sur cette
journée merci mélanie pour ceux qui
voudraient relever quelques challenge
des concours sont organisés à dès 16h30
notamment un concours de précision c'est
ça on retrouve plusieurs idées de sortie
dans quelques instants après ce journal
votre émission le 7-8 loisirs voilà pour
faire le point sur les principales idées
de sorties à faire dans l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines et aussi
dans le département merci mélanie